you tell a lot of stories in your book
was there anything you left out like too
crazy to put in the book oh don't you
think let me pee and I'll get that
[__] publisher bro I almost canceled
this book
they scared they're petrified okay tell
us what what did the publisher not want
to put in they didn't want to use a lot
of the names you know which I understood
so I had to go back
and go through names again and see what
the [__] can't you put this name they
didn't want any names where
there were crimes involved with that
person okay you know a lot of stories I
told for that person I I told that first
name but not their last name yeah and I
changed to another guy's name apart and
then some of the stories were just
you know I mean some of them were
[__] out there
and we had to lock those up you know
just to make the story just to make it
flow a little bit more yeah [__] like
that like we used to 93 when I was in
the city doing comedy
I have been doing comedy for three years
at that point and I wanted to come back
here I just [__] the bed in Boulder yeah
I was like I need to walk the streets
where I grew up I need to come home and
[__] walk these streets you know I
would take the [__] I would go up to
181st and Take the A Train down and
[__] loved it I love everything about
that my favorite part of this whole city
is 181st Street at that time because I
would go to Carvel I would get a dime
bag on 174th Street I knew that area
right by the medical center there's a
Cuban restaurant up there I just love
that area so
so when I came back in 93 a buddy of
mine that I was tight with
I asked people want to make some money
when I'm doing like drug rips and he had
DEA contacts so he had the badge and the
jackets and [__] and our job was just to
go up to that area and case out drug
dealers and one of the stories that
nobody ever believed that me and this
kid saw we were just parked outside of a
building like and we could see people
going in to buy drugs and [__]
and we were there for like two days and
one day A guy got in the car and saw us
and he went on the West Side Highway
and we were like behind them and like a
mile away he pulled into that spot like
on 90th Street and he just ran away from
the car
he got so paranoid he thought we were
cops that he pulled over and just ran
like what the [__] so he went like 25
minutes I go and my buddy when I went to
the car opened this trunk and they had
two kilos in there just like that and
that's how I got back to Colorado in 93.
with that money yes
it never ended dog what a great hustle
just have the DEA outfit on in the car
wait for someone to act wild follow them
until they leave their [__] that's I
mean the guy must have saw us like two
days in a row he got paranoid you know
I've been there I called the cops up
myself a few times and [__] what do you
mean oh 90 90 80 86 in in Aspen I was
living in Snowmass house sitting and my
girlfriend at the time went for a
wedding that I was supposed to go to but
I busted into the ounce of coke on a
Friday night that I had saved for like a
month and now I couldn't leave the
[__] apartment
like I could not leave that [__]
house where I was house sitting and I
mean I was so paranoid I wouldn't even
let the dog out to go pee she kept
looking at me like Peter were coming out
of his ears because I got to go out and
pee I'm like you're not going out there
there's cops out there and [__] I got so
paranoid that weekend that I called the
cops three times on myself
you know this burglars on the property
and they would walk around there's no
burglars the last time the cop said to
me Mr Diaz when was the last time he did
a line of coke please put the bag away
wow and that was it